things are not always what they seem you
especially see this
in the case of FTX
and Sam bankman freed have you seen this
guy
if he isolated I have no idea what this
was
because you know me I'm a boomer you
know I'm older than a boomer I'm
whatever Joe Biden is that's what I am
at least in my mind that's at least how
I identify so I'm not really into crypto
or you know computers or I don't know
Donkey Kong or whatever you kids are
playing out there so I I didn't know who
this guy was or what his exchange was
FTX was a crypto exchange headquartered
in the Bahamas it was launched in 2019
it had accrued one million users by this
year
and all of a sudden
users demanded their money so there was
a run on this exchange they demanded six
billion dollars in withdrawals
and the exchange collapsed why did they
demand the 6 billion in withdrawals they
demanded it because of an article
published by coindesk which revealed
that the two arms of this guy's Empire
Sam bankman freed were sharing a lot of
assets we're doing lots of dodgy stuff
so he had the The Exchange and he had
sort of like a hedge fund and that there
was a back door that was allowing the
money to go between the two and so their
balance sheets were totally bogus and
the thing was pretty much a Ponzi scheme
this comes out
bankman freed
goes broke and I'm not sure that people
even know where he is right now it's
just he's either the Madoff of Our
Generation or it's the Enron of Our
Generation it's a major major Financial
Scandal and crime and collapse now why
does that matter I always thought the
crypto thing was weird so I never got
all that into it but but people got you
know people I mean major institutions
invested in crypto and so
why does it matter
why is it interesting to us well it has
nothing to do with crypto or the Bahamas
or anything like that has everything to
do with Sam bankman Freed's
extracurricular activities
is Hobbies
bankman freed was the number two donor
to the Democratic party this cycle
number one is George Soros you're not
allowed to say that though it's an
anti-semitic conspiracy theory to
mention who the largest owner to the
Democrat Party is George Soros who is
don't think he's exactly a practicing
Jew last I checked but anyway the libs
tell me it's an anti-semitic conspiracy
theory and I'm not allowed to mention
that he's the number one donor well the
number two donor is this guy Sam bankman
freed Sam bankman freed gave at least 38
million dollars to left-wing causes and
political action committees committees
and candidates
this is what they do
this is what the libs do
they
use their clout they use their social
Prestige they use their money
to
puff up even more their semblance of
virtue they make it seem like they're
the most altruistic wonderful caring
people in the world and yet the point is
always to give them breathing room and
to give them an opportunity to fill
their pockets more and more
you see this on some of the great reset
when we talk about the great reset the
fact that the libs are trying to make
people eat bugs and the lips are trying
to make people live in these gigantic
awful skyscrapers and these tiny little
pods and that they're the the great
reset which is this project of the world
economic Forum which involves some of
the most powerful people on Earth who
say explicitly you will own nothing and
be happy you will you will not have any
possessions
well the the flowery arguments that they
make at their conference in Davos is
that this is this is for the good of
humanity this will allow the human
Collective to grow and progress
and the the funny thing about all of
their schemes and their plans a lot of
which revolve around climate change but
they but they have all sorts of other
doomsday prophecies uh overpopulation
and all the rest of it the funny thing
about all their schemes to address all
of these Armageddon scenarios
is that all the schemes always seem to
make those people richer isn't that kind
of weird
it's not it's not just simple enough to
say well this is a movement from the
radical leftists who are trying to push
their utopian Vision in the world yeah
sure that's part of it
it's also capital
it's also deeply entrenched moneyed
interests who use all this woke nonsense
as a smoke screen to fill their pockets
more and more
it's also that and that's what you saw
from Sam bankman freed
but it was all
an illusion today's music Monday we've
got a t-swift video
again I I don't think I've ever
intentionally listened to an entire
Taylor Swift song
in my whole life I don't really know
anything about the girl but her last
song
seemed to me fairly conservative which
was jarring to me because I was told she
was a huge limb so anyway the producers
of teed up a t-swift song the rest of
the show continues now if you don't want
to miss it then you got to become a
member and of course you don't want to
miss it so click the link in the
description and join us
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]